elle salue bonsoir et eu peur big up
pour lisser le monde on a commencé dans
la classe moyenne est maintenant on est
autant mais pour ce soir micasa
lms enfin bref j'suis sûr que vous
connaissez aussi la fin de l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
on est arrivé là
la pop star xavier également acteur et
célèbre philanthrope a été retrouvé mort
ce soir nous son corps a été découvert
au pied de la falaise alors qu'il
donnait une fête après la soirée des
anciens élèves de son lycée pour moi
c'est un meurtre hu
n'apporte lequel d'entre vous pourraient
être le meurtrier je veux entendre votre
version il se passe un événement mais
chacun le voit sous un angle différent
votre propre scénario votre film mental
vous avez vu ses cheveux on dirait qu'il
a roulé une pelle à un horaire où
l'ouragan je suis juive c'est génétique
ils ont un super volume moi ce que je
veux c'est découvrir qui a assassiné
xavier vous êtes tous allés à la soirée
des anciens du lycée pour quelles
raisons avoir une seconde chance dans la
vie en amour pour autre chose
j'ai juste envie de sauter tout ça pour
aller direct à la mort de xavier je vous
raconte une histoire je construirai
personnage ya une dynamique qui
s'installe
tout le monde ici des tests et xavier
c'est les pierres des pertes qu'il est
là avec ce petit costume violet non mais
honnêtement à quoi ça rime d'être torse
poil je savais qu'ils cherchent à saper
t ai montré cpcq imberbe hu
tout le monde semble penser que tu es
coupable ouais tout le monde
ils parlent tous que de ça
pardon désolé il n'y a rien de marrant
on peut tous pété les plombs quoi qui
[Musique]
vous voulez peut-être avoué un autre
parce qu'on doit trouver le meurtrier ce
soir
tout le monde ici semble cacher des
choses
sow le spectacle est terminé mais vous
saviez pas que c'était un faux et vous
l'avez quand même décapité sans broncher
et rappelé faisant
[Musique]